Tom Arban Gervais joins us now a jhelum
river that flows from northern India
into eastern Pakistan Osama good to see
you
what's the situation right now how many
people are affected but surely we in the
last few minutes we've spoken to the
National Disaster Management Authority
which says that at least 1200 people
have been evacuated to safety 18
villages have been affected and three
are completely underwater as you
mentioned there are a few people who are
refusing to leave because this is the
time where they're closer to harvesting
their crop their livelihood is at stake
because their livestock is where they
are and they want the government to
assure them that if they leave they will
have something when they come back or
when they go to something they will have
some sort of sustenance because they do
not want to leave their life belongings
behind as you mentioned earlier
Pakistani officials in the last 48 hours
have been accusing India of releasing
this water hundreds of thousands of q.6
of water into the suit alleged River and
not informing the Pakistani authorities
which was their deal early according to
bilateral agreements now that
communication link has been established
and both water commissioner are a
commissioners are in touch with each
other but this monsoon deluge is nothing
new it happens every year but what is
happening this time around is that it is
happening at the at the juncture where
Pakistan and India are at one of their
lowest points in relationship and both
countries accuse each other of
weaponizing everything including water
and Osama politically things as you
mentioned are extremely tender has there
been any attempt at an explanation as to
why there was no warning we haven't
heard from the Indian side yet we've
only heard the accusations from Pakistan
and and there's a lot of diplomatic
activity that is happening right now and
water has just become one more of those
issues that have been added to the list
in the last 24 hours we've seen the US
President Donald Trump speaking to
leaders on both sides by Cassini Prime
Minister coming again expressing his
views on Twitter saying that it is the
fascist Nazi ideology that Park
and Kashmiri czar facing in terms of the
Indian government so it is very very
tense between these two nuclear-armed
neighbors it is worth noting that
because of these bilateral agreements
these governments are are supposed to
inform each other whenever there is
there is rain and this is it's like
clockwork it happens every year when
there is monsoon season it is very hard
glacial ice melts and India releases
water what is happening this time around
is that probably that phone call or that
email did not happen and Pakistan has
raised alarm bells there the military
has issued statements that the water is
still rising and it has put its forces
on the highest level of alert not just
on the borders but also in places which
are vulnerable to floods some Punjab a
there reporting a forest Osama thank you